ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show we are here again
for your viewing and listening pleasure
uh the shirt i am wearing today 911 a
closer look
tim j dillon uh brought to me uh
by uh three gentlemen forget their names
at the stress factory comedy club in new
jersey i appreciate that this is of
course a call back
to the uh joke i said that this is the
class that i would teach
if i was a teacher and
three gentlemen bring it up to me they
gave it to me it's a little small
but that's all right about day five
aikido we're we're turning over a new
leaf
and uh a little small but i i wear it on
the show to thank those gentlemen
they came up to me and go you could sell
them just give us half gross
gross just give someone so what do you
everybody's gary vee
relax and be happy i enjoyed it it was a
nice
thing what are we going into business
together i don't know the [ __ ] you are
you still man just give us half what are
you
nuts oh yeah get on the team
fill out a w-9 we'll just salary
everybody let's put you on a salary
you could come up with some more ideas
thanks for all the work you put into the
shirt
giving you half for what you think i
can't do that
i hope they sue me in intellectual
property court we've sold 75
000 of these i'm a trillionaire
i'm not selling 911 shirts buddy calm
down
i do appreciate it and i like it thank
you
the fires are finally starting to calm
down now the fire department in los
angeles clearly an incompetent
group of lazy people that cannot do
anything has finally by accident
somehow made some progress with these
fires
okay how about going to work
i saw we had breakfast the other day i
see one of these lugs
just with a fire truck on a suburban
street standing there
and i said i'm sorry
are there not things for you to be doing
at this particular moment
i think the firefighters are starting
the fires to try to get relevant
because they're jealous that everybody's
talking about cops
so the firemen are now lighting [ __ ] up
so they can get some goddamn attention
okay pretty childish bobcat fire spreads
to 60
555 acres while still threatening mount
wilson
and the san gabriel mountain communities
several areas in the angelus national
forest remain under evacuation orders as
containment of the blaze increased to 15
so they've increased uh they've they're
more successful at containing the fire
than they were well hey
good job maybe we'll get to 17
what's going on over there it's not hard
it's fire
and water put it in a hose
and put it out what are you doing
standing and looking at it
it's pretty easy if you ever had a small
fire in the kitchen
yeah it's easy you put water or you put
the lid on the thing
and get the air out get the air out put
a tarp on it tarp it up
tarp it up it's over don't [ __ ] stand
around
trying to feel because you know
everything now is about you know
oh it's so hard
it's the easiest thing ever there's a
fire what puts it out water we know that
this isn't coronavirus where we're
searching for the vaccine
we know the enemy of fire is water
point the hose at the fire and
put it out
am i wrong truly am i wrong here if i'm
wrong tell me
i don't think you are i don't think i'm
wrong either
we got a bunch of degenerates running
around
not putting out the fires put the water
on the fire
do it from a helicopter or do it from a
hose
what happens on the show see i started
this is kind of a bit but as i'm going
into it i do think i'm
almost right like as i'm leaning into
this more
i kind of believe that i'm not all wrong
here
what the wind is blowing the fight then
point the hose where the wind's blowing
how about making all of it wet so that
it can't catch fire
just start soaking [ __ ] get some super
soakers remember those when you're a kid
you could do super soaker
you could have fun have fun with it go
out in the forest with the super soakers
it's fun it's fun and productive it's
fun and nobody dies
have a water gun fight it's fun
and you make progress with the fire i
mean these things are going on for weeks
what are these slugs doing i'm genuinely
curious
go up in the helicopter spray the hose
from above it
i'm i'm confused does anyone out there
understand what's happening
it can only be that these firefighters
are enjoying this because they're sick
[ __ ] that's what i think they're sick
people and they like watching things
burn
who becomes a firefighter anyway what's
that about
you like heat
it's a little wild i'm just saying reign
it in boys
we've had enough the citizens of
california
have had enough how great would it be if
newsom got out and just threw him under
the bus
he goes we have the most incompetent
fire department
i mean these people can't [ __ ] do
anything
i mean god they can't do
anything this thing's been burning for
weeks
they know it they know where it's gonna
go they just don't care they're always
shocked
it also happens every year why are we
always shocked that the fire's coming
get a clue as roseanne would say dumbass
she called me a dumbass dumbass
in other positive news in los angeles
people are now moving
boulders under the freeways to keep the
homeless from
living there if you've been to los
angeles which many people are leaving
many are evacuating ben shapiro
took 75 jobs to nashville tennessee
joe rogan took one job to texas he took
jamie vernon
so a lot there's an exodus out of
california people are leaving they've
had
enough the homelessness
has reached a crisis point
under most overpasses in california you
see large tent cities
communities hoovervilles if you will
only to be made worse by current
economic conditions
but what does a functional society do
when presented with such an issue what
does a functional
society do we take boulders
and we put them under the bridges so the
homeless people can't set up tents there
we take spikes and put them places
so they can't sit down we put rings on
the benches
in the park so they can't sleep we make
la
into a level of super mario brothers so
no one can
ever rest ever again we have those
thromps and that's what they're called
those big stone things
fall down on the homeless people if they
for a second
pause and look like they're going to set
up shop
this can't be the solution okay
other than the fact that it's pretty
inhumane it can't be the solution of a
functional society
to just build a lava pit where the
homeless people were
that can't work i don't know what will
work but that just doesn't
is there more of a sign of a
dysfunctional society
than two guys walking under an overpass
with a boulder
and putting it down could there be any
sign that this dish
i mean just turn the lights on the way
out this place is [ __ ] done
then two schmucks
walking around with large rocks how
creepy is that
so you drive into the uh underpass now
there's no homeless people there's just
rocks there's boulders everywhere
hollywood screenwriter behind point
break and varsity blues moved boulders
into west los angeles freeway underpass
to keep homeless people
out on of the hottest weekend of the
year
interesting a hollywood screenwriter
helped arrange to have 60 boulders lined
up on a pedestrian sidewalk in los
angeles
to keep homeless people from setting up
tents in the shaded area
on a day when temperatures reached 111
degrees
so i imagine people are not too happy
with this gentleman right people are
probably angry about that la's a pretty
liberal place
la screenwriter sets up large spikes
to discourage homeless people from
sitting
in said area it is out of control i
think it's nuts that a homeless person
can set up a tent outside of your house
they're maybe mentally unstable they're
a drug addict it could be a pedophile
they're hanging out you got kids you
don't want somebody like that that could
be potentially dangerous i think it's
weird
that the cops won't break that up i
agree with that
but i think the the solution must be
bigger
than just uh rigging an obstacle course
around los angeles that homeless people
have to now go through you know
hollywood screenwriter has put up
hurdles
so that homeless people have to learn
how to jump in order to get
i mean we need some investments in
mental health care
we need housing and look at how much
housing is going to be for homeless
people
this is crazy what the [ __ ]
are they doing they say la's homeless
housing now costs more
than some luxury condos 746 thousand
dollars
per unit
and i don't know why it cost so much i
imagine because of regulations and
i don't know but 746
000 per unit
for a homeless person for a homeless i
mean
that seems a little high
prop hhh tax dollars were intended to
facilitate development of up to 10
000 units of housing for la's homeless
four years later only 228 units have
been built
good job what are you guys in league
with the fire department
the cost per unit to the tax papers
taxpayers keeps rising
and construction on some projects is
behind
we have a crisis on our streets last
year we had a thousand people who died
on our streets so this is a question of
life and death
gal parental the i-team which is that
news team yeah
galpran says the rising cost of building
housing for the homeless is due partly
to the red tape involved in getting
projects approved
there should be no red tape getting
how safe do these [ __ ] things
have to be it's safer than under an
underpass
what is this million dollar listing get
the [ __ ]
boxes up put the beds in them and we're
done here
what is some lunatic walking around
going my concern is the finishes
because a lot of my a lot of my clients
really want you know high-end finishes
granite marble uh what are the acoustics
on the wood it's very important we don't
want the rooms to be too loud
put the bed on the floor move on
heat air conditioning that's it running
water
god's name is taking so [ __ ] long
here's the problem what happens is and i
get this people
don't want these low-income low-cost
homeless housing in their areas
that's what it is and that's probably
part of the reason it takes a while for
these things to get approved
we just have to convince the homeless
that la's over they got to get out of
here they can be homeless anywhere now
they don't need to be here do you
understand
they can do their jobs from anywhere
it's hot
people here are stingy they're not
giving there's not a ton of tourists to
to get over on maybe think about
new orleans or another place let's
redirect the homeless and try to give
them
the idea that they can go somewhere else
and have a better chance of duping
tourists
better climate more open spaces
there's so many places to go in this
country if you're homeless
there's so and we should have a campaign
for this we should come out
la should say we want to remind the
homeless that we
love having you here and we've loved
having you here
but this is a big wide open country with
so much space that's why
that's why people say to me tim you're
so negative about america
no no i'm not i understand
the great things about this country one
of them being
that there are so many places to go if
you're homeless
that is such a positive that's never
talked about
we always talk about the other great
things about our country like our
healthcare or education systems but we
never discuss
how great it is to be homeless here the
absolute
freedom the utter joy of being homeless
in a town with a high influx of tourists
many of them will give you things you
don't even have to have a weapon just
look threatening and they will they will
call
many of them are drunk and you could
push them down on the way back to their
hotel
and grab something from them so what is
all the negativity about america things
are actually pretty good
so we need to just have that campaign if
you are homeless in la
if you're unfortunate enough to be
homeless in l.a i don't understand the
homelessness crisis in l.a
because they're they they say how many
people we got on the street now
in la county it's like sixty thousand
sixty thousand in l.a county here's you
know what my problem with that is it
should be a lot
more most people i know should be
homeless here
i have a conversation with someone the
first thing i do here is how do you have
a home
how do you have a car i'm shocked that
half of the city is not homeless
i mean it's a city without any talent
right truly
the dearth of talent here is
mind-boggling
and yet people have figured out a way i
don't know what they do
they get a job working for some rich
person fingering their cat
while they're on vacation and somehow
they [ __ ] they live in their back
house
but the way i see it nobody should have
a [ __ ] home here
apple sucks raycon is the move get the
raycon earbuds they're much better when
you lose your apple earbuds when you go
in there they're gonna [ __ ] bang you
out for a lot of money
raycon is much cheaper works just as
well if not better i'm telling you
six hours of play time seamless
bluetooth pairing more
bass uh more compact design a noise
isolating fit
raycon earbuds are stylish and discreet
no dangling wires or stems the company
was founded by ray j and everybody loves
it snoop dogg mike tyson everybody
melissa etheridge
they're all obsessed with raycon
products give them a try raycon has a 45
day free return policy so you can make
sure
that they're um the pair of wireless
earbuds for you
if you want to support the show and you
need her butts they're great by the way
raycon earbuds here's what you do you
buy them
you keep them in a draw if you ever ever
or you can switch to them and use them
which is great but the way the way i
really like to play it
is if you buy them you keep them in a
draw and if you're apple ear buds if
any there's ever a problem with them you
don't have insurance you lose them you
just go right to the recon
it's super easy or what i do this is
what i do
we have two sets of earbuds you have one
that never leaves your house
which could be maybe your apple or
whatever and then you buy a raycon you
put them in your car
you travel with them or whatever i think
you need two sets of earbuds
you know one could get dirty this that
and the other thing you know it's it's
very important that you you pay the [ __ ]
attention what i'm saying right now
because i swear to christ if you [ __ ]
this up i'll come there and i'll kill
you personally
okay because you don't deserve to live
on this planet do you understand that
you don't deserve to live if you don't
buy the right kind of your bud
you realize how stupid you look
do you realize how stupid you look to
regular people
if you lose your earbuds you don't have
a backup do you realize that people
don't care what happens to you or your
family
if you lose your earbuds and you don't
have a backup ready
by raycon you know what happened the
other day
my mother lost her earbuds
she goes i don't know what to do i said
will you shut the [ __ ] up
you stupid [ __ ]
she said why are you talking to me like
that i said you should have got ray kind
of your buds it's a great backup
should have all kinds of different
earbuds she said i don't like the way to
talk to me i said i don't like the way
you're [ __ ] acting you [ __ ]
she said what i said you heard what the
[ __ ] i said
she said you're good in this man about
earbuds i said yes
because it's important that you wake the
[ __ ] up
for once in your [ __ ] life
by raycon.com tim that's by
com tim for a special 15 discount on
rake on wireless earbuds
make sure to check it out now while the
deal's running
ladies and gentlemen mental health is a
big deal right now
everybody is nuts that's out there
they're all bonkers they're all
batshit crazy you need to get help and
it's during the time of covet you can't
see a therapist it's a whole problem i'm
telling you right now there is a
solution it's better help
better h-e-l-p better help h-e-l-p
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
okay better help will access your needs
and match you with your own licensed
professional therapist you can start
communicating in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help as a professional counseling
done securely online
don't like your counselor you could
change at any time there is a broad
range of expertise available which may
not be
locally available in many areas
depending on where you live the service
is available for clients worldwide
better help is communicated is committed
to facilitating great therapeutic
matches so if they make it easy
and free to change counselors if you
need to
it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available better help
wants you to start living a happier life
today i've said this many many times
it is important to get your mental
health in order it is so essential if
you want to succeed
develop a positive relationship be a
better husband mother
father sister brother lover whatever you
want to do out there
a human trafficker whatever business
you're in you gotta be
mentally together okay it's the easiest
way to ensure you're not gonna make it
is if you're not together mentally okay
so betterhelp wants you to start living
a happier life today
visit their website and read their
testimonials that are posted daily
visit betterhelp.com that's betterhelp
and join the over 1 million people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help
of an experienced professional in fact
so many people have been using better
help that they're recruiting a digital
counselor special offer
get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com timd
betterhelp.comtimd use the service use
my promo code tell me what you think
dm me on instagram or twitter or
whatever not twitter i don't follow you
but instagram and uh i will
read your testimonial on the show if you
enjoyed uh betterhelp or if you don't
like it let me know
we want to recommend products that you
guys like so
uh you know me and ray did that uh thing
where we called the better help ad
uh on the patreon episode i think so
there's that and then there's also this
so go to
betterhelp.comtimdbetterhelp.com
tim d thank you
airbnb is v is really disrupting
real estate and i know a lot about real
estate i just did a little fake business
now you know that i do this a lot of the
audience don't know that i do i do fake
business
i call up realtors all day when i'm
bored
and i pretend i'm a realtor and that my
client is very interested in their
property and i ask them lots of
questions about their property
i just did it with a commercial property
on
palm canyon drive i said hey this is tim
uh i have a client of investor that's
really interested in the property what
are we looking at per square foot and
what are some of the local restrictions
we should know about
and you know these whole things they go
into this whole thing they go well
you know they don't want a coffee shop
in there because starbucks there's a
competing business clause
so starbucks doesn't want a coffee shop
this is how the corporate takeover of
america is by the way
because when starbucks moves into an
area they go yeah we don't need we don't
want some independent coffee shop
opening
not all areas but a lot of them we don't
need somebody slinging lattes for less
than we are so the guy goes
well there's a sprint store so we can't
do a competing business blah blah blah
and we talked about it there's a lot of
parking behind i said thank you i said i
have an investor but he's very concerned
about you know the competing business
clause and everything like that i was on
the phone this guy for about 10 minutes
and he's saying oh tim that's cruel
their time has value
no it doesn't and i will continue to do
fake business
because i enjoy i like doing fake
business it's one of my favorite things
to do i like to call people
and i like to lie about who i am and and
and what i do
and then i like to see how they conduct
business because on their end
they're conducting real business i'm
conducting fake business
now never the two shall meet we've
gotten to the point where i was we're
almost
one of my clients who doesn't exist was
almost going to put an offer on a house
this was last week i was i've been on
the phone with this realtor for like 45
minutes three times in a row i've had
the blocker finally she doesn't know
what happened
sometimes i have to block the people
because fake business gets very intense
fake business people start drawing up
contracts i mean she was calling
appraisers she was gonna have
inspections done
you know i'm was representing a very
motivated overseas client
now sadly that client died of
coronavirus
before we could go see the property
that's not my fault and i tried to
explain that to her
but she was kind of confused and started
saying oh this you know blah blah blah
are you real is this real cops fbi
whatever blah blah blah blocked
blocked i'm helping train these
professionals
do you understand yes or yes i by
calling them
people need practice so this schmuck
over there on palm canyon i did use my
real name by the way
like this is tim dillon and sometimes i
make up a firm name sometimes i use a
real firm name
sometimes i just say this is tim dillon
with futures he does what like a futures
investment
he goes okay you just go okay go yeah
all right
i go yeah you got a commercial listing
on palm canyon on the corner
i'm wondering what we're looking at
price per square foot what's the parking
in the area like
what's the competing business clause
well any local restrictions we should
know about
i have a team of investors that are
looking to expand into this area many of
them uh
sometimes it's a franchise sometimes not
but i'm just you know it's an investment
group they're very interested they love
the visibility of the location oh he
goes it's a great location
so they love the visibility of the look
and see right there we're beginning to
do
fake business because then he goes to
his wife and goes
i just got a call from a guy that may be
interested in this
and then he tells the secretary and then
he tells his partner so
i'm in i'm in and i'll give him a
follow-up call later tonight i'll have
10 more bullet point questions before i
bring my investiture
i do this a lot of people
i was explaining to someone at dinner
that i did i do this and it goes it's
horrible
i said why i'm doing fake business
they go why i said i like doing it so i
don't have a real estate license
and i can't do real business but i at
least can do fake business
they said that's pretty sick i said
maybe you're sick
because i want realtors to get the best
professional
i want your golf a lot right
when you golf when you golf every day
are you better at it
yes absolutely now that doesn't matt now
even that includes going to a driving
range sure
right correct right sometimes i see
golfers swing clubs in their backyard
helps helps doesn't matter if it's real
or fake
what matters is that this guy's going
through the moat the next guy to call
him might be real
but i'm gonna beat that guy out i'm
gonna do a competitive offer
because i conduct fake business well and
many people don't
a lot of people do things people go on
fake diets i've done a ton of them
people do all kinds of things that
aren't real people are fake comedians
they pretend to be a comedian for a
decade and impoverish themselves
and live on a floor and walk dogs fine
that's all when you go home to your
family for thanksgiving and you go i'm a
comedian
they're eating and they're like no
you're not you're a pretend comedian
you're a fake comedian
i am a fake real estate investor and i i
will continue to do fake business
so if you get a call from a guy that
sounds
like me just be forewarned
the deal's not closing the deal is not
closing
i have an interest in presenting myself
i have a lot of clients when i do fake
business
they're very busy many of them are
overseas
they cannot handle i mean we should
probably get the phone do a little fake
business right now
maybe we get our phone can you get the
phone let's do a little fake business
because i don't think people understand
what i bring to the table and how good i
really
am do you have my is that my phone
let me call this guy back how did we get
him in the road caster is he in the road
caster
hello hey adam tim dillon how are you we
spoke about the property on palm canyon
a few minutes ago
yeah hey tim how's it going good buddy
how are you i wanted to know if there's
a list
of the competing clause uh my client's
asking me if there's a list
of businesses whether it's starbucks
sprint things like that
that we could kind of figure out what
the restrictions are just so i could
kind of email that to them because he
wants to show it to the
his investors if that's possible also is
there a way they can get out to see the
proper
property maybe later in the week
yeah yeah i live about four minutes from
it so not too
difficult that and um
uh i will just go to the center right
now and send you a quick list of all
the businesses that are in there all
right i would appreciate that let me ask
you a question too how long has this
probably been on the market i have i
haven't looked it up yet
yeah i've been marketing it for maybe i
think
i was i just signed it like right when
covet hit and then
i delayed it for like two or three
months so i'd say maybe like two or
three months now
okay and before you had it was it was it
sitting there for a while or no they
always like to know these things
yeah i don't i know banner mattress was
there up until recently
okay um so i know there's a mattress
right across the street yeah i saw that
is this would this be a five year lease
or what do we what are they looking for
in terms of
commitment yeah it really just depends
on the
the tenant and the rate and things like
that obviously the longer the
commitment the better we can do on the
rate um
but um you know i think they're open
right now okay and
i imagine i imagine they're open to some
form of negotiation
at you know given the climate of course
okay well i appreciate that we're here
to do deals yeah
me too but i mean me too
it's a little wild out there you know
are you guys mainly commercial you do
any residential
um i do a bit of both okay good yeah you
got to be kind of a generalist out here
i i agree yeah a lot of people are
starting to get interested in this area
and i think it's because
you know la's had a lot of problems and
a lot of
a lot of my clients i do business
primarily in in los angeles
and a lot of people are starting to look
at this area
and um you know a lot of them are are
excited about maybe jumping into
uh something here you know because the
high season i imagine it's what january
through through june
uh yeah january through april is our
high high season right um but we're
pretty much like right now like
september through
april um you know so we have kind of we
kind of have like a shoulder mid-season
uh which is september through december
right um and then january
april just crushes and then uh coachella
is obviously
in stagecoach earned april and that kind
of you know
and we have a memorial day weekend july
4th
during the summer of course i appreciate
that well listen i have you guys i have
your website
i'm gonna shoot you an email um just
again introducing myself and then if you
could just get me a list of some of
those competing business clauses just so
i can show it to them
and uh hopefully they'll get out to see
it sometime uh
next week you know they're they're super
interested one of them lives out here in
rancho
and uh they pass it all the time so they
had me just kind of reach out to you
and see what was going on but they're
pretty motivated and again
i think it's all about you know how
restrictive those clauses are
yeah i i think they're going to be
pretty flexible so i'll shoot you the
businesses
yes and uh we'll see if we can do
something okay i appreciate it adam
thanks a lot for your time
all right thank you so do it's fake
business
and i'm doing it well i'm doing it well
let's be honest i'm doing it well
i'm protecting the interests of my
clients
am i not am i not protecting the
interests of my clients
when i conduct fake business my fake
clients
are important and they need to be
protected
i want them to have the maximum amount
of freedom
in any given situation you understand
start doing fake business it'll change
your life i'm telling you that right now
start doing it no one can start you
don't need a license
you just need a phone and a computer
and you can start doing fake business
set up a fake email address i have one
start doing fake business right now it's
the gateway to real business
are you bored are you sitting around
at home you don't know what to do build
a fake empire of whatever business you
choose
you don't need any type of license to do
this
you can just call people and
be the person you've always been meant
to be i think i've always meant to be
sort of a rainmaker putting together
deals
a guy with a six-pack and a huge [ __ ]
[ __ ] people of every gender doesn't
matter maybe connected to intelligence
maybe not
power broker type of guy and that's what
i now of course
i'm not that i'm negotiating commercial
real estate mattress transactions to
rancho mirage it doesn't only
fake business doesn't always work out
the way you want it to
i wanted to be fake cia i can't do that
but i'm a fake realtor in the [ __ ]
desert
even your fake life will not be as great
you see even you're pretending even in
my pretend life
i'm just a shitty realtor looking to
sniff out a bach
but i know who i am i know who i am in
my real life and my fake life and that's
what's the most important thing
set the expectations for your fake
business
high but reasonable this is my advice to
you
gary vaynerchuk tells you to start a
real business oh i say no no
i say start a fake one start a pretend
business
you can do everything that you will do
in a real business there's much less
risk
sure these people get upset after a
while after you've called them 17 or 18
times
you have to make up stories about what
happened to your investor why didn't you
show up to the showing
you were in the hospital it's easy to do
i'm just telling you it's important oh
tim these people's time is valuable no
it's not
no it's not they love it all they do all
day is talk to 90 people one of them
signs a contract
i'm one of the fake people until the
contract is signed
all business for intents and purposes is
fake
business and i am one of the best
that's what i've been doing here to keep
myself sane
[Music]
i mean right now i'm negotiating a strip
mall in connecticut
you see that's much more
it's much more complex because there's
many different
storefronts you see see what i mean
as you get better at fake business you
have to start looking things up you got
to know tax numbers you got to know
profit and loss i mean you got to really
know your stuff
if you want to start talking to real i
have some real deal people i talk to
they're legit they make real money and
they think i'm a realtor
you know they think i represent an
investment group
so that's what i think you should do if
i had to choose how you spend your time
it would be that lucy nicotine is a
company founded by caltech scientists
and former smokers looking for a better
and cleaner nicotine alternative finally
tobacco alternatives that don't suck
listen smoking is bad it increases your
risk for all kinds of problems not the
least of which is corona lucius created
a nicotine gum
with four milligrams of nicotine it
comes in three flavors winter green
cinnamon pomegranate smoking's out
vaping's even out too ben's got to stop
vaping but he can't one day he's gonna
wake up
and his lungs are going to be like
because he's just
stupid because he should be smarter but
he's not i love him and care about him
and i want him to succeed and that's why
i'm going to get him a ton of nicotine
gum so that he can finally
start being the type of person uh that
that
i i would like to uh respect
it's 20 20. get rid of your cigarettes
unplug your vape and throw out your dip
get some loose nicotine gum or lozenges
this is the real deal
subscription to lucy directly to your
door each month it's so simple you don't
have to leave your house lucy has
delivery down
tim dillon show listeners go to lucy.co
lucy.co
use promo code tim tim to get 20 of all
products including gum or losses i'm
dead serious about this guys
it's a great thing uh you can use it to
stop smoking stop
vaping dip is gross you don't want to be
doing that you also got to be the person
the type of person that can dip and not
look like a lunatic
red comp never was you'd walk around
with vanilla skull or treasure
dipping and spitting spinning in a
[ __ ] poland spring bottle it was a
mess
you don't want to be that person okay
i'm telling you right now
lucy is really great everybody likes it
everybody
loves it so if you're a smoker out there
lucy.co
if you are a smoker lucy.co promo code
tim
20 off do it also i have to give this
disclaimer
the product contains nicotine which is
derived from tobacco nicotine is an
addictive chemical
but it's a lot better than smoking
because then you don't get the tar
and all the carcinogens and all those
cancer causing agents
so sure go and get
lucy.co use promo code tim if you like
my show
you want to support it this is a great
way to do it if you don't smoke start
smoking get addicted and then quit
using lucy it's easy to start smoking
and i'll tell you how
thank you rich wallet yum
every day i wake up and i have a level
wallace
and i hate myself and my family
and friends and then i got a rich
a titanium wallet
minimal front pocket and it was designed
to streamline what i carry
every day and i'll put a rich and be
great if it's a country song like i put
a ridge in my pocket
it's my new wallet and i went down to
the lake and i said
how do i live in a country where all the
news is fake
i took my titanium wallet and i said
metal feels good
not as good as a gun i
love guns i like shooting guns at people
that look differently than i do
sometimes someone looks differently than
you
and they eat spicy food and you have to
kill them
buy it with the ridge i mean how many
christ
for christ how many times do i have to
tell you to buy this [ __ ] wallet i've
been talking about this
for two years it is a small metal wallet
you can easily sanitize it
you put it in between your hands you
[ __ ] sanitize it with the sanitizer
it goes right back in your pocket nobody
knows you have it
so when [ __ ] really hits the fan and
people are robbing you and everything
they're not gonna know you have the
[ __ ]
ridge it's so easy it's so
simple everybody in the [ __ ] world
has one but you you dumb
[ __ ] how ignorant are you you ignorant
piece of [ __ ]
sitting there with a leather [ __ ]
wallet how many [ __ ] cats were
skinned for that how many animals die
for your convenience every day you cruel
[ __ ]
it comes at titanium carbon fiber
aluminum and over a dozen different
styles
and colors get 10 off today free
worldwide shipping and returns ridge.com
that's ridge.com tim and user code tim
link in description 10 off today free
worldwide shipping and returns
i'm telling you right now folks don't be
like my idiot father who bought four of
them and didn't use my promo code that's
just his way of [ __ ] me
ridge.com t-i-m-ridge.com it is so
[ __ ] important do it now you're not
gonna want to have a big bulging wallet
in the front pocket of your pants when
people come to kill you
ridge.com tim but la is getting tougher
to live in it's getting harder to
justify living here
many people are leaving the state tax in
los angeles
is 13 13
state tax and then it goes
up they're trying to make it
17 that's almost 20
of your money for high earners
higher earners are people that earn a
million dollars a year
now obviously we're not crying for
anyone that makes a million dollars a
year
but if you're making a million dollars a
year in a business where you don't have
to be in california
and you can go somewhere else and not
pay
really high taxes it would be one thing
if the high taxes led to people having
better lives
that's what interested many people about
bernie sanders he was from outside
of the system he was going to come in we
were all going to pay higher taxes
but people are going to be able to start
getting health care and coverage
and it was going to be a transition and
it might take years maybe even a decade
and there would be some pain involved
but at the end of that situation
perhaps i don't know if it would have
worked or not it was worth maybe
trying at the end of that situation you
were going to potentially have
uh coverage for people and then if
you're going to pay higher taxes the
idea of having health coverage
makes a lot of sense to just pay higher
taxes so that we can
continue to build drones to bomb uh kids
playing soccer in pakistan
uh doesn't make any sense to me
okay these pretend wars and by the way
what do you think the government's doing
out there
fake business doing a lot of fake wars
that we don't need to [ __ ] fight and
we're paying for it
if these taxes went to something that
was actually verifiable
maybe people would be more into i don't
know where we're gonna end up i don't
know
ben is from texas he's ready to go back
there he's ready to go back
get baptized again start speaking in
tongues he'll do it
he'll do it they put him right in the
lake
he wants to go down there and stare at
the sun
go into the woods see the devil fight
him
maybe lose but show up for the fight
he remembers that how he grew up and he
might go back to that
i might put him right back in a cult i
might start a mega church
yes i would be a great mega church
pastor
great tent preacher sweaty a tent
i could be so good at that he has never
forgotten about you
but you have forgotten about him
he has never forgotten you say that over
and over again
whip them up into a frenzy
this thing by the way so airbnb here's
the way i want to talk about airbnb
right now because airbnb is very
interesting and then we're going to talk
about that satanic house on airbnb
because i think that's very funny
somebody went to an airbnb and said uh i
think i'm about to be sacrificed
so they left a lot of long-term
rentals on airbnb right now are are are
are really fairly priced
especially in big cities like new york
or l.a a lot
and i learned this from james altucher
the guy who wrote that new york is dead
article
who is a part owner investor in the
stand-up new york mossad
scam that is a comedy club in new york
city which is a front uh
to send weapons to the idf which is fine
but let's let's call things what they
are um
and james altucher said people are
getting great deals long-term airbnbs
you do not you don't have to there's no
broker fee
there's no credit there's no [ __ ]
it's no risk for the people renting out
because you pay up front
and your credit is your reviews on
airbnb
so that's probably what i'll do for the
next six months to a year until i find
out where i want to live or where i'm
gonna go
i'll just hop around to different
airbnbs obviously if you have a family
that's harder
but it is much easier now to do two or
three month rentals
in airbnbs you could hop around from
area to area to see which one you really
like
they're all furnished they're you know
you look at the reviews they're well
reviewed if you're
well reviewed you're not going in and
trashing people's homes you don't have
to deal with realtors
brokers broker fees credit financial
documents
any of that [ __ ] you don't have to show
up with tax returns there's no approval
process
it's so simple what this is the perfect
way to do it
it really is now the problem is you got
to come up with the money up front
but if you could do something within
your budget and you have a couple of
months of rent saved
boom just like that you're in it's not a
big deal
but that is really interesting what is
happening and you look at all these
realtors you're like well what are all
these realtors gonna [ __ ] do
what are all these real estate you know
agents going to do that primarily cater
to the rental market you know like uber
airbnb and this is really the thing with
capitalism it's like
you do have these real it is kind of an
issue here
where you just have these companies that
are very efficient
they come into a market they disrupt it
which i hate that word but that is
what's happening
and then they realign the market so that
they trim the fat
and the fat is a lot of people's
livelihoods
a lot of people make a living on that
fat chewing on that fat
and a lot of companies and these tech
giants
that are worth billions of dollars
employ
very few people compare so then you
think maybe the realtors transition into
property managers
maybe they transition into maybe you
know the cleaning crews now are working
you know especially because of culvert
but also uh you know they have to flip
the property and have to go in there and
clean
um you know there may be
places jobs for people to transition to
i hope so
you know um and that's you know that's
what i see happening is very interesting
i spoke to somebody real estate and
they're like airbnb
is is very interesting and it's taking a
lot of
um a lot of the
process which is annoying the process
you don't have to go see the house you
don't have to do it you just look at the
pictures they're high def people go the
pictures look exactly like the house
you read the reviews you go good i'm in
that's it's easy
you pay a cleaning fee you pay up front
and then you're just kind of in you can
stay there two three four months
whatever
you know you could stay a month say [ __ ]
it i hate it i'm going somewhere else
you know and this really works for
people that don't have a lot of [ __ ]
if you have a lot of stuff i live out of
a bag i have clothes that's it
i don't want to furnish anything ever
truly i have no interior design
you know it's the least gay thing about
me that i don't like interior design
also that i look and sound the way i do
but i don't care i want to buy a
furniture if i go to texas i'm getting a
furnished place
somebody also furnitured somebody else
will do it couples love doing that
couples like walking around stores they
have nothing to do
i don't know i think is this the lamp
that we like
is this that is that this is what it is
i don't have any time i'm doing fake
business and trying to save the world
i'm entertaining people i don't give a
[ __ ] about the coffee table does it work
but airbnb is very interesting so this
guy frederick joseph who is he by the
way this guy frederick joseph
i like him author the black friend
forbes
under 30 marketer founder
former national surrogate for elizabeth
warren and bernie sanders fair enough
okay i like this guy because i i like
when people
invite you into their private lives to
make a public point
yeah i like this i'm gonna read his
whole thread here on twitter he's trying
to get a refund from airbnb but i've
i've kind of done things like this i
give up because i want to just
insult the company and lie about what
happened
more than i actually want my money back
so i will you know i was famously in a
feud with dan kim the ceo over at mango
frozen yogurt um and then i would i
would say that i was raped in his
store and to me it was more important
because i just said let us make our own
yogurt because they still made it for
you at red mango you know
it was the heyday of self-serving this
[ __ ] would so then i just
started claiming i was being
raped in his store and that there were
rapes happening in store
now that was more important to me than
any type of real change
do you see what i mean i was just trying
to use buzzwords to get attention
and to upset him i just want to upset
people
on social media more than i want to get
something
frederick joseph says we just drove
three hours my eight-year-old
wait a minute we just drove three hours
my eight-year-old brother for a getaway
okay another thing folks let's do the
grammar a little bit if we're gonna go
out and call out a company and try to
make a little money which i have nothing
against
we just drove three hours my
eight-year-old brother for getaway in
the house we arrived at
ended up having seemingly satanic items
and stuff for witchcraft
rituals we had to leave because my
brother and the rest of us were
frightened but airbnb won't refund me
thread so now the first four pictures
are abacomets
you know the uh so go up here
we got uh bahamut which is creepy
because it's got
it's the goat figure with the satanic
pentagram
and then two children looking up at
bahamut
and then next to it is a picture of a
goat it is creepy
the people that own this house are
probably satanists but many satanists
aren't really
dangerous they're annoying
they're just people that tried to get
into something because they couldn't
figure anything else out they're like
i'm gonna put a bunch of candles around
my apartment
hopefully my life now has meaning
spoiler alert
it does not it does not
your embrace of the dark arts
notwithstanding go to work
please i rented this house to do writing
and spend time with my fiance brother
and cousin already i don't love that
idea
already i don't love the idea of you
going with your fiance brother and
cousin
to do right why are you going somewhere
to do writing
with three other people i don't believe
you're doing any writing
be honest i rented the house to work out
and i and i brought with me a cake
it doesn't make any sense i call out
companies
all the time but again i'm never looking
for a refund i'm just looking to get
someone in the company very nervous
about something
even for a split second and then they
find out i'm a comedian and then move on
but even for just a split second if
somebody at red mango has to read the
words
i was sexually assaulted
in your uh frozen yogurt shop
and i started doing this because i had
the chocolate sorbet
soft serve which had sorbitol in it or
sugar alcohol which made me [ __ ] myself
for 72 hours
like i had dengue fever i basically had
malaria
okay it was not nice so then in order to
kind of right the wrong there i then
started tweeting at red mango that i was
viciously attacked i had to delete the
tweets i was in danger of being
removed from twitter
i rented this house to do some writing
lie and spend time with my fiancee
brother and cousin it seemed like a nice
place pretty basic layout from the
listing
pictures below but as we drove up we
noticed there were no other houses in
the area
just rundown shacks and no phone signal
now what do you think ben ben you think
everything's satanic benjamin
every time we see a gnarled branch of a
tree ben thinks it's a scene at a true
detective
because he's always looking for satan
that's what he's always looking for
satan he just wants someone
to care about him even if that person is
trying to kill him
man just wants somebody other than his
lovely wife he just wants somebody out
there
to notice him besides me and he thinks
that person will be the dark lord
what if how what a lofty ideal you think
satan's trying to find you
she can go golf
does this seem weird to you that there
was nowhere else up there
no this is just people trying to be edgy
right i think so but let's go on we're
not done with this yet
okay okay when we walked up to the house
we noticed an animal skull hanging on
the outside of the house so i went
by the way i had an experience like this
at an airbnb montauk
and it was all native american stuff
yeah and i'm not
saying that native americans are satan
but they've got some animal skulls and
some things it was a motif
if the decor was not for me especially
because it was a white woman named sarah
okay now you know the way i feel about
cultural appropriation i think it's
[ __ ]
but i do get uncomfortable when a pretty
peppy white chick serves me chicken and
waffles
i want a mean middle-aged black woman
who's seen things
to hand me my chicken and waffles okay
and i want her to call me sugar
and then i want her to go in the back of
the restaurant and say
call me that big [ __ ]
i don't want some girl who went to
oberlin college
i don't want somebody named sarah
running out of shack and montauk and
[ __ ] you know thinking she's
pocahontas because she's threw a bunch
of
[ __ ] quilts in it
[Music]
sarah you're the person that gave them
the smallpox blankets
you
when i walked to the bay when i walked i
went to the basement and found more
animal skulls and ritualistic floor
markings where were they did you have
photos of them i don't think so and then
i went up to the rooms to find much
more it is a creepy house a little bit
as you walk through the two rooms you
found a bunch of imagery candles books
etc for rituals and what looked like
devil worship my brother was terrified
as were we
we called airbnb see i would have fun if
i was a satanist and i had this type of
house
it is creepy i would put a picture of
john podesta in the kitchen
and a picture of hillary clinton just
fun have a little fun with it
have a little fun with it we called
airbnb and told them we couldn't stay
there and explain the situation
keep going down we were told that we
couldn't receive a refund and they spoke
to the owner
who said they were just a few small art
pieces and that they could come remove
this was a lie it was a whole damn house
not a few things a bahamat
hidden behind a dead bird in a bag
there was also a bridge from the woods
behind the house to the back patio
needless to say
we left because we are black i don't
know what that is
but i guess it's like a movie like
they're like this is a horror movie
we're black we know this works yeah i
guess
but i get it black white asian
whatever pacific islander
norse people nordics whatever who's ever
out there
i understand this is creepy needless to
say we left because we were black and
not dealing
with something that was one advertised
completely different
would it be funny if you went to the
airbnb listing and they were like it
literally says
satan's lair you know there's some angry
airbnb persons like
it says satan's lair in the description
it says for losers who couldn't finish a
screenplay
that now have an interest in [ __ ]
satanism
weird german philosophers and the dark
arts
looks like a scene from hereditary
made the entire family feel unsafe all
of that to say this isn't our guest
should be treated i use airbnb
frequently and there are many reasons in
this situation which would warrant a
refund especially our safety mental
emotional health
so a lot of people uh we closed that out
but there's a lot of people on twitter
that are now like hey [ __ ]
crosses make me feel uncomfortable yeah
i saw that i go to airbnb all the time
there's lots of religious artifacts that
make me feel
uncomfortable why should you get a
refund i walk in a house i see buddhas
i see all kinds of statues that are not
in line with my religion
i don't know which side i come down on
this i think it's a little creepy
and then people are like welcome to the
country it's like that's not it
that's not the take dummy city guy
doesn't understand the country
it's a creepy house we would have stayed
in it yes
we would have stayed i would not have
asked for a refund um
[Music]
you know
i'd fill that house with a bunch of
people to make to satan satan is scared
stand-up comedians desperate
sad comics
you think uh uh human sacrifice is scary
have you ever seen
uh somebody over 40 to a tick tock that
ain't good either
that ain't nice either but i would have
stayed there i don't think i would have
asked for a refund
i don't believe in that black magic
where i don't think you can get me i'm
pr
baby i'm protected i protected the light
of the lord
i will redecorate that house in magga
[ __ ]
they'll come back to that airbnb they'll
come back to that airbnb
guess who's on the porch that looks like
tim dylan and candace owens
and we're singing that martina mcbride
song he independent
let freedom ring
let the wand of sing
let the whole world oh that today
oscar's got an ak
it's a day of reckoning
what if i just replaced all the bahamats
with pictures of oscar
in a maga hat stop being a puss about
everything so satan has owned a house
they might have sacrificed a few people
out who cares
i'm glad they're in the country whatever
i'm your beeswax my friend josh's jewish
mother you said i'll tell you mind your
beeswax
she also said once i was eating french
toast it was disgusting she was have you
ever had such
jewish cooking it's like this is
horrible
eileen this is horrific it's very very
bad
the holla is not sufficiently submerged
in
that's the thing about keto and i've
been on it for
a few days and uh the mental clarity i
have is
is good and you know ben is still eating
sugar because he's weak
and weak people constantly
um you know go back to what makes them
comfortable but i have no problem
journeying out
and really holding myself accountable
and kind of running my body like a
machine i run this
like a machine not the machine of course
that's bert
but uh i uh it is interesting
and you start you think of carbs
like it's a little you just you kind of
you kind of look at carbs you never ate
you never cared about and you they seem
like enticing and alluring
what's your favorite breakfast
carbohydrate
if you had to pick a breakfast
let me give you the options okay so you
don't say something
completely absurd and derailed the
entire
broadcast as you've done many times
before
which is why lisa ayat will be here very
soon lee's coming
i'm shipping lisayet in fedex he'll be
joining the program
oh he's here right now hello
you stay there until we're ready i'm
kidding i'm kidding
hype means nothing i like lee i love lee
and joey in the church and the
whatever it is whatever else i love
everyone um
my love for everyone is immeasurable
you can't measure it can you measure it
correct what is your favorite the
choices are pancakes waffles and uh
french toast oh man what well
why are you shocked that those are the
choices i thought you were gonna throw
bagel in there
oh okay are you ready pancakes
waffles french toast those are the
choices
it's pancakes for sure
very interesting let me explain to you
the breakfast carbohydrate uh pyramid
for
for those of you who are out there who
are not on keto that might want to
indulge in these things
pancakes are
[Laughter]
they are the most edible
because they are made well with the
highest frequency
okay you go out and order pancakes
they're good 80 of the time
the waffle you go down to 50
now french toast now here's the [ __ ]
thing listen up
if done well if
executed perfectly without a [ __ ]
smidgen of uh of a
inaccuracy it has to be done to the tea
every morsel perfect
french toast is the best if it is really
done well
but it is rarely done well french toast
has only done well
30 of the time these are
scientific figures from being fat for 20
20 years
25 years these are scientific
figures studies i've done across the
country doesn't matter
across the world french toast can be
amazing
the best type of french toast really is
there's all kinds of breads you can use
for french toast but really good is just
that white trash
wonder bread type of french toast that's
really good ton of butter in a pan
nice and soft store-bought syrup never
that vermont [ __ ] it's never as good
that gooey
uh you know uh what is it basically that
syrup is basically just uh
high fructose corn syrup that's all it
is uh you know
um and that's really good but if you
have truly transcendent french toast i'm
talking about
little orange rind little orange zest
little tahitian vanilla
like there's a few things that can be
done the french toast that make it
it elevates french toast pancakes are
amazing
respect level waffle love the belgian
waffles soft
fat belgian waffle in america not the
hard [ __ ] they gnaw on in brussels [ __ ]
you oh it's the liege waffle you shut
the [ __ ] up we know you love hitler
but waffles are often too crispy
they're burnt they're dry they're not
good
they become crackers you dip in syrup
it's a problem
pancakes can get too fat too fluffy too
bready too dry
they need to have a life to them the
best pancakes are at the clinton street
baking company in new york city
why because they're soft in the middle
but on the outside they have that little
hardened
brown butter loop and that is hardened
because it is the way your parents used
to make them because parents the butter
would not go in the pan they didn't know
the butter was all over the pan and it
would kind of unevenly kind of cook the
pancake
so when you're eating the pancake from
the clinton street bacon company you
remember when you thought there was love
in the world
that's why they're so good because you
remember when the world made sense and
you thought there was love and now of
course you realize that those were child
childish fantasies that we are living in
hell and we are all
demons but that pancake
makes you feel better there's a great
place called
burnt toast in algonquin illinois elgin
they make a phenomenal french toast get
burnt toast up right now let's give
birth toast a little free [ __ ] uh you
know advertising my
friend um we dropped his hooker
girlfriend back off there she's not a
hooker she was a stripper she was kind
of a hooker it doesn't matter she's in
jail
we call her blagojevich she has a couple
of kids different races she's very woke
we respect her the point is this
we went there to drop her dogs off to
her um
and we i i had breakfast at this place
this place is such a [ __ ] good
breakfast place
they have grand marnier french toast
there and let me tell you right now
it'll change your [ __ ]
life where is it what's going on i don't
love these new pictures what's happening
i got french toast sticks
here no i don't like that at all
interesting i don't like this at all
something's happening and i'm on
i'm i don't like it i'm i'm about to
launch into a
a diatribe that is against you can you
just google image
burnt toast elgin illinois
uh french toast let's try to find this
skeleton
elgin yeah i don't know why it's not
it's not coming up here
send me a photo do you have yelp or
tripadvisor or anything yeah let's get
on yelp
go on yelp because this is great french
toast and if you send me a picture
of your banana bread french toast
i will do absolutely nothing but i will
repost it
if you're in that area this is if you
really want to get some killer french
toast out there and you're in chicago if
you're in chicago
you want to get some good french toast
here we're going to
show you how that works it's really good
breakfast place
my friend ryan loved him he's in rehab
now
and uh so we could just find
let's just keep scrolling down let's try
to find the french chest i i don't know
why
this is such a [ __ ] problem so here
here go to the left
go left a little bit okay go down okay
to the right
this one
so this is kind of their i think the
regular french toast and it's got the
banana stuff on it this doesn't look
good and it's not photographed well this
is kind of
not i don't know see what's grand
marnier french toast comes with bananas
and walnuts on top so the grand marnier
french toast
is really good it is good indeed this
doesn't look good get this out of here
x out of all of this [ __ ] i'm sick of
trying to help places that don't know
how to market
do you know how much work i put into
fake business
you know how much how many [ __ ] i
wonder how many people could be mad at
me for just calling random people
probably no one who cares
doesn't matter what else is going on we
are on the road let's get the
dates up and let's figure out where
we're going to be come see us live it's
a lot of fun
fort worth hyenas comedy club friday
september 25th
also two shows there dallas all sold out
but we've
added another show so get tickets to
that two show saturday we got a sunday
show in dallas
nashville is selling out we're adding a
show in nashville salt lake city adding
a show
phoenix buy those tickets we don't have
to add yet tampa adding a show
okay so nashville and tampa we are
adding shows
phoenix are tickets still available
nashville and temple we've added a show
you can get tickets now
dallas show's added you can get tickets
now west palm beach
october 22nd through the 24th lot of fun
please show up and have jobs unlike
those instagram influencers i performed
for thank you to gila eli klein what's
her name
ela gila gila yeah she was the best
audience member of them all and she
laughed and she understood language
uh some of those uh uh uh uh ladies
in the crowd the whole thing they were
like this
they didn't understand i think if
there's not a phone like this they don't
know they're alive
there's got to be a phone like this if
you hold it near them it's like a magnet
it's like
but other than that they're they're down
for the count but thank you to the h3h3
lady for uh being a very responsive
audience member she was a lot of
fun but again we're gonna be we're gonna
be out all these places uh we're gonna
be
uh doing some fun [ __ ] and then we're
kind of shutting down for the holidays
and uh you know for we're gonna do some
stuff in early november too
denver potentially some other places but
then we're shutting down for the rest of
november and then probably also for
december
or we're gonna go back out on the road
sometime next year
um you know we're going to be picking
uh some different markets we're gonna
have some overseas stuff
hopefully spoke to a doctor today about
covert he's like listen it's not
political it should have never been
political
um you know he goes we've had 10 deaths
from the regular flu in the in the
coachella valley
this year so he said listen man he goes
i know you don't like wearing the masks
but
he goes it does help he goes it does
help and he goes we're getting better at
treating this over the last 60 days he
did say that
the vaccines that are coming out the
three big ones pfizer astrazeneca and
somebody else i forget moderna those
three moderna
pfizer and astrazeneca which um are the
three vaccine candidates because they're
very safe but they may not be effective
he goes when you have a vaccine the most
important thing is that it is safe
because effective doesn't really matter
if it doesn't work it doesn't work you
just you can get another one
but what you don't want is any adverse
health effects and he goes he's going to
read a little bit more and
before he gives it to himself and his
children but he did say they've gotten a
lot better at treating covet
um but he did say that they don't know
what's going to happen if you have
covert in the regular flu and blah blah
i mean the reality is the problem has
become this is such a political
football for both sides that we've lost
you just go talk to a doctor talk to a
person with a lab coat on that has a
medical degree
because it can be like yeah it's real it
[ __ ] people up this is what it is you
gotta you know distance or whatever
but also it's not the end of the world
and you you know that we will
he says we're probably six months we're
being kind of really out of that we have
to go through the winter so like
it's hopeful it's also like you know
wouldn't it be great if he said um if i
said what do you think the deals at
chronovirus he said
lock the door
what he goes
there is no coronavirus this is a
military operation because
there is a satanic pedophile cabal led
by tom
hanks we have released this disease
ourself
because the one that hillary clinton was
going to release was going to be a lot
worse that
would have killed everybody but this is
not that bad
we're releasing it so that we can have a
total shutdown of the american
electrical grid in the internet
which will allow an army of people that
donald trump has personally selected
to go and serve 120 000 subpoenas
because
even though these are satanic pedophile
cannibals we need to subpoena them we
have to indict them we have to do this
the right way
even though they are dark arch magicians
that are murdering children
we have to do it the right way this is
why donald trump is in office to do this
so that's what the coronavirus is so you
don't really have to wear a mask or do
any of the distancing
but just prepare yourself for the three
days of darkness
and for the arrests of everyone in the
political system the media in hollywood
now you can unlock the door
and i just look at him and i go
wow and he goes also you have adult
[Laughter]
eczema
that's what i was expecting but he
actually had a pretty reasonable
explanation that involved
data and numbers boring
but that is what is out there so you got
to be careful but we're doing all of
these shows are safe
to the degree that they can be they're
socially distanced
you know you got to take uh take
responsibility i'm going to be out there
where i'm masking up on the plane
wearing some [ __ ]
face shield or whatever i have to do um
and then once we get in the club we we
we will be funny and then we'll all
leave we're not going to do meet and
greets we're not going to
hug it's just you move on you know
and uh that's gonna be the solution
um we're gonna run now because the
episode is over but more importantly i
have a lot of stuff to do on that
commercial property
right now i'm palm canyon i have to
start looking at
cash flow statements profit loss kind of
a big deal
so i will have you ever done fake
business
no but i've seen you do it millions of
times not cut out for it
you're not cut out for it that's not an
insult but you're not cut out for it
there's a certain type of person that is
cut out to build an empire that doesn't
really exist and i am that person
so anybody out there answering a phone
call trying to do business
beware because i'm coming
and i have the facts and the stats
and that deal is not going to close in
fact i'm going to be like a vaper
like this guy used to call me all the
time he had all these motivated clients
whatever happened to that guy
that guy disappeared he's just sitting
on the porch of a satanic b
b with candace owens and a great cat
loading ak-47s
and singing songs because the power of
christ
will not be beaten good night